this video is brought to you by
squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
squarespaces the all-in-one platforms
build a beautiful online presence and
run your business check out squarespace
through the link in the description
below
more on them in a bit
during the 1910s hollywood california
established itself as the new and
undisputed mecca of the budding film
industry already its movies were hits
throughout the united states and its
stars were some of the most famous and
glamorous people in the country placed
by the public on a pedestal above us
mere mortals the 1920s were a different
matter though as several controversies
began to take some of the shine off
hollywood to reveal the grime underneath
the decade started with the suspicious
death of actress olive thomas who had a
tumultuous marriage to actor jack
pickford then in 1921 the death of
virginia rap at a party hosted by large
and life comedian fatty arbuckle who
then stood trial for murder became the
biggest scandal in the nation the
tabloids eagerly fanned the flames of
the controversy looking to milk the
story dry but if you want to get the
full picture we already actually covered
fatty arbuckle on this channel so do
check it out it's not what you think
anyway hollywood was still reeling from
the arbuckle affair where they got hit
with another scandal the murder of
director william desmond taylor once
again the newspapers had a field day
with the salacious details uncovered in
the investigation fake identity
compromising photographs a drug and
sex-filled party life a secret family an
underage love affair revengeful mother
the story really had it all and that of
course was without taking into account
the actual killing of william desmond
taylor which involves several hollywood
stars and remains an unsolved murder to
this very day
[Music]
william desmond taylor was born william
cunningham dean tanner on april 26 1872
in carlow county in carlow ireland he
was one of five children to thomas
khan's dean tanner and jane o'brien and
he grew up on quite a lavish estate in
the irish countryside his family wasn't
among the movers and shakers but they
were definitely well off jane o'brien
had inherited plenty of land from her
own father while thomas dean tanner was
a retired major with the british army
the senior dean tanner expected william
to follow in his footsteps and embrace
the army life but even from a young age
the boy was more interested in the
forming arts his father would hear
absolutely none of it though and he sent
william to clifton college in bristol
where he studied engineering however
being away from the family farm also
granted william a modicum of
independence soon after he turned 18 he
took a trip to manchester where he saw a
famous stage actor of that time charles
hawtry perform in his biggest hit a
fascicle play dubbed the private
secretary william became so enraptured
by the performance that he decided that
this was the life he wanted to pursue
after the show he plucked up the courage
to approach hawtery and ask him for a
job on his production william claimed he
had lots of experience an obvious lie
but maybe he caught torture in a good
mood or maybe the veteran actor saw
something in the boy either way he gave
william a small part in the show this
was taylor's big break in the
entertainment business but it didn't
last during one production of the
private secretary in london some of his
family acquaintances were in attendance
they recognized william and promptly
called his father to inform him of his
son's new career choice suffice to say
that thomas dean tanner was not pleased
he summoned his son back home and
decided that he needed to go someplace
far far away from the temptation of the
stage and just like that in 1891 william
found himself transported from the
hustle and bustle of london to a farm in
the middle of nowhere in harper kansas
we're not sure exactly what the plan was
did william's father hope that some time
away would rid him of his artistic
fancies or did he renounce his son
completely either way william's passion
did not doom in the slightest he worked
for a few years as a farmer then when
the klondike gold rush came in he
traveled to alaska where he became a
minor putting that engineering
background to good use but during all
these years he still found time to act
taking to the stage in between farming
and mining seasons once again he met
someone who understood his potential
this time it was stage actress fanny
davenport and she gave him roles in many
of the plays that she starred in
davenport died in 1898 at which point
william decided to travel the country
for a bit eventually ending up in new
york city there he met an actress named
ethel may harrison and the two of them
married in 1901 and had a daughter named
ethel daisy williams new father-in-law
was a wealthy wall street broker got him
a job managing a fancy antique furniture
store on fifth avenue more than that his
connections and reputation instantly
elevated william and his family into a
higher class of society aided by william
himself who made quite a bit of money
while mining in alaska in other words
this could have been his new life that
of a successful businessman among new
york's upper class but it still wasn't
the life that he wanted the call of the
limelight proved to be so overpowering
that in 1908 william simply disappeared
he took off leaving his family behind
and when he finally re-emerged he was
not william cunningham dean tanner
anymore he was william desmond taylor
the years immediately following taylor's
disappearance are a bit blank some say
that he went with the most obvious
choice and resumed his acting career
while others claim he traveled north to
the yukon and worked as minor again
around 1912 however he finally emerged
in california under his new name looking
to take his acting from the stage to the
silver screen remember that hollywood
was just beginning to emerge as the hip
new place to make a movie other
locations like new york city and fort
lee new jersey were where the american
film industry was born but many more
movie companies were already looking to
move to the west coast and if you want
to know why it had a lot to do with
thomas edison the inventor at patent on
a lot of technology relevant to movie
making and he tried to monopolize the
industry by making sure that nobody
could make or show a film without him
getting a cut those who tried were sued
or had their equipment confiscated so
it's not too surprising that production
companies sought greener pastures
therefore they moved to the opposite end
of the country as a middle finger to
edison whose influence didn't quite
reach that far by 1910 companies like
biograph and selig polyscope opened the
first movie studios in los angeles and
they were quickly followed by many
others among these was the new york
motion picture company which gave
william desmond taylor his first role in
december 1912 in a movie titled the
counterfeiter this was followed by
several other roles in 1913 for the same
company until taylor switched to
biotograph where he began filming
westerns his biggest hit at the time was
a drama titled captain alvarez where
taylor played the lead role apparently
taylor developed her reputation of
treating everyone the same both stars
and extras and was so well liked on the
set that the people who worked with him
all chipped in and got him a snazzy
leather portfolio as a gift with the
inscription to william taylor actor
goodfellow and gentleman who will always
be thought of by the undersigned as
captain alvarez it was only when this
movie came out that taylor's wife
finally found out what had happened to
him when she saw him on the big screen
by that point ethel may had legally
divorced him in absentia but she
contacted him in hollywood and the
couple reconciled somewhat they never
got back together taylor was engaged to
actress neither gerber until 1919 but he
did visit his family every now and then
and made his daughter his legal heir in
return his ex-wife kept the shameful
episode of taylor's life a secret from
the public alright we'll get back to our
video in just a second but first here's
a word from today's video sponsor
squarespace you know what's great about
summer vacation time off a little bit of
r r it's the perfect time to spend a
little time on the beach daydreaming
about the next project that you want to
start fortunately squarespace gives you
every possible tool you might want to
fashion that next project whether it's a
small business a sports blog a creative
portfolio or just a page full of dank
memes it doesn't matter if you can dream
it you can build it with squarespace are
you looking to get in and out quick
without thinking too much about what
your website should look like
bam well just use one of their quick
beautiful templates to make a website
that's fresh and for you or maybe you're
more of a hands-on person you've got
lots of opinions and ideas about what
exactly your site should look like well
squarespace gives you all the
customization options you could ever
want with no updates no patches no
technical nonsense to worry about and
once you've done setting up your website
tinkering with the design if you're so
inclined or maybe just playing around
with the colors there are so many extra
features that squarespace provides so
that your site can thrive emac campaigns
patronage portals social integrations
member-only areas analytics commercial
options 24 7 customer support really
everything you need is in one place so
when you're ready to get started on the
next project of yours big or small it
involves a website it's got to be with
squarespace go to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch your new site go to
squarespace.com forward slash
biographics and you'll save 10 of your
first purchase of a website or domain
and let's get back to it
after biograph taylor worked with balboa
studios based in long beach california
this was an important step in his career
because balboa allowed taylor to direct
his first movie and as much as he loved
being on stage he soon discovered that
he preferred to be behind the camera
from then on taylor only took a handful
of small acting roles before making the
switch permanently to directing he
worked with multiple companies such as
palace pictures the american film
company and fox films until 1917 when
william desmond taylor joined famous
players lasky the precursor paramount
pictures and stayed with them for the
remainder of his career taylor directed
almost 60 movies although most of them
are lost today he worked with many
popular stars at the silent era
including mary pickford wallace berry
and wallace reed but a particular note
was mary mars minter who would later
find herself in the middle of the
scandal surrounding taylor's murder in
early 1918 taylor directed mary pickford
in a movie titled joanna enlists a
comedy where the protagonist falls in
love with a soldier it was one of many
films made around this time that
showcased the admirable qualities of the
men fighting in world war 1 which were
used both as morale boosters and as
recruitment tools this particular movie
had the desired effect on at least one
person because after he finished
shooting it william taylor took a little
vacation and then he enlisted in the
british army in august 1918 taylor
arrived at camp ford edward in nova
scotia canada as a priver with the raw
fusiliers of the british army once again
taylor proved incredibly popular with
the people around him as his ncos
described him as a fine fellow a
gentleman in every sense of the word and
a man who never thought of himself who
was always helping the underdog that
being said taylor might have had a
slightly glamorized image of military
life as he arrived at the camp wearing
several diamonds and packing a wardrobe
full of fine expensive clothing which he
then had to send back to los angeles
ultimately though taylor got the hang of
things and his ability to learn quickly
his willingness to follow orders without
comment and his popularity with the
other men ensured that he rose quickly
through the ranks he was made corporal
within three weeks of his arrival at the
camp then sergeant and finally sergeant
major in just two months by the time
taylor was actually sent to england he
had a lieutenant's commission and let's
not kid ourselves no matter how likable
the guy was this was all because he was
a famous movie director not because he
was some kind of military mastermind we
don't think taylor actually saw any
action he was placed in a non-fighting
unit and stationed at dunkirk with the
army service corps of the expeditionary
forces canteen service but it was after
the armistice in may 1919 taylor
returned to los angeles and was honored
with a homecoming victory dinner by the
motion picture directors association he
resumed his movie career and scored two
of his biggest hits when he directed the
screen adaptations of two popular books
of the day anne of green gables and
huckleberry finn everything seemed to be
going his way but not for long
on the morning of february the 2nd 1922
taylor's valet henry peavy entered the
living room only to find his employer
lying on the floor the valet tried
waking him but it soon became clear that
taylor was dead no wounds or injuries
were readily apparent which made peevy
think the director died of natural
causes two months shy of his 50th
birthday this might explain why some of
taylor's acquaintances were told of his
death before the police allegedly the
cops were only notified 12 hours after
the crime and when they finally showed
up at taylor's bungalow in the affluent
west lake neighborhood of los angeles
they found execs from famous players
lasky burning documents in the fireplace
while actress mabel normand was
frantically searching through taylor's
office looking for incriminating
photographs we say allegedly here
because everything that happened from
now on has been tainted by rumors gossip
and media speculation that make it
almost impossible to separate facts from
fiction anyway the cops inspected
taylor's body and when they turned it
over they saw the director didn't die of
natural causes after all he'd been shot
obviously this changed the complexion of
the case the police wanted to
reconstruct william desmond taylor's
final hours and assemble a list of
people who might have wanted him dead
his friends and colleagues were
terrified of the negative publicity that
this would generate meanwhile william
randolph hearst and his ilk were
salivating at the idea that they had
another hollywood scandal on their hands
to fill the pages even though their
fatty arbuckle trials weren't even yet
over almost immediately newshounds
discovered that william desmond taylor
was actually william cunningham dean
tanner and that he had had a secret
family that he abandoned years ago
already the story was getting juicy but
it's just getting started according to
the timeline established by the police
mabel normand would have been the last
person to see taylor alive other than
his killer of course she arrived at his
home on the night of february the first
at around 7 pm and stayed less than an
hour when she left both were in good
spirits and norman's car drove away
while the two of them blew kisses at
each other it seems that taylor was
slain just minutes later at around 8 pm
several neighbors heard a noise that
sounded like a car back firing but was
most likely the gunshot that killed the
director faith mclean the wife of actor
douglas maclean said that she'd looked
out the window and saw a dark figure
wearing a long coat walking out of the
house she assumed it was a man but the
person had their collar up a cap over
their face and had an effeminate walk so
it could also have been a woman
right away investigators thought the
butler did it bit of a cliche perhaps
but the police were willing to overlook
this small detail if it closed the case
this wasn't the current butler mind you
henry peavy but taylor's former butler
edward sand who got sacked in 1921 for
stealing from his employer and forging
checks in his name a bit of looking into
his past revealed that sans was just an
alias and that his real name was snyder
and he had a history of petty crimes
sans also had broken into taylor's home
after being fired to steal some more so
he knew how to gain access however he
disappeared after the murder and was
never seen again at one point someone
claiming to be sans wrote to los angeles
district attorney thomas warwind and
offered evidence that would clear him of
the crime and name the true killer if
all other charges against him were
dropped however this person never
followed up on the offer so the true
fate of edward sands is still a mystery
although he remains the favorite suspect
of many taylor's current butler henry
peavy was also briefly a suspect because
he was the one who discovered the body
the police cleared him pretty quickly
however but it seems their efforts were
not good enough for the office of the
los angeles examiner which became
convinced the pv was the culprit and
went to insane lengths to try and prove
it seriously if we didn't have the
statement from the district attorney
this would have been almost unbelievable
first a couple of reporters from the
examiner showed up at the house and
pretended to be police officers from new
york and asked pv to accompany them to
the newspaper officers to answer some
questions when he said no they offered
him a thousand dollars and that got him
moving at the building they kept pv in a
locked office for 12 hours basically
holding him hostage when they finally
released him at night they only gave him
ten dollars and instead of taking him
home they drove him to the cemetery
where taylor was buried basically their
premise was this because henry pv was an
uneducated black man the reporters
thought that they could scare a
confession out of him they took a walk
through the cemetery talking about
spiritualists and ghosts to set the mood
at which point another man wearing a
white sheet appeared claiming to be the
spirit of william taylor and urging the
butler to confess to his murder their
foolproof scooby-doo plot didn't work
because one henry peavey wasn't
superstitious two he wasn't an idiot and
three he seemed to be the only person
there aware that the real taylor spoke
with a british accent unlike the ghost
who sounded like a gangster off the
streets of chicago d.a woolwind later
denounced the examiner in a statement
that said henry peavey was taken from
his room by a pair of conscious black
guards who represented themselves to be
officers of the law and held a prisoner
from noon until about midnight on last
sunday during this imprisonment he was
subjected to the most outrageous
treatment he was held for hours in the
office of the los angeles examiner not
even being permitted to leave the
premises to get necessary food when he
became hungry to add to the unspeakable
injustice of this high-handed procedure
he was conveyed to the cemetery by night
by these two scoundrels who first took
him from this room and another rascal
who joined them was taken to the tomb of
his former employer and every effort
made to bully and terrorize him i feel
it is my duty as district attorney of
los angeles county to expose such vile
cowardly and unlawful practices for the
perpetrators of which every decent
citizen should feel a most supreme and
utter contempt although not as unique
and exciting as the pv incident another
possible scenario involved mabel normand
the exact nature of the relationship
between taylor and normand remains up to
debate due to media rumors and
speculation but it ran the gamut from
one extreme to the other some said that
taylor was a closeted gay man and that
his relationship with norwood was purely
platonic in an attempt by the movie
studio to hide his sexual orientation
others went in the opposite direction
and accused the director of being a
serial womanizer who often took
pornographic photographs of his liaisons
and kept a collection of monogrammed
women's lingerie as mementos of his
conquests either way two things were for
certain one the two of them were madly
fond of each other even if they were
just friends and two mabel normand had a
coke habit taylor tried to help her get
treatment several times without success
and eventually he thought that the
situation called for more drastic action
by turning in her dealers to the police
unfortunately for him they found out
about his plan and they were not too
pleased the quick in and out without
leaving evidence the single shot these
all suggest that the murder could have
been a professional hit in which case
the perpetrator could have been someone
looking to silence the director and
protect their racket but even more
outrageous than a murderer's drug ring
was the relationship between william
desmond taylor and actress mary mars
minter and her mother minter was a
former child star who was 30 years
younger than taylor and became the
director's protege when the police
discovered that minter had written
taylor several love letters the
salacious story in the headlines was
that the two were having an affair that
began when minter was 17 years old the
girl's mother charlotte shelby was a
failed actress who lived vicariously
through her two daughters and exerted a
domineering control over their careers
therefore when she found out about the
relationship she feared that it could
ruin mary's acting career so she took
matters into her own hands and gunned
down william taylor it's a pretty
convincing story but the only thing that
we can say with a fair degree of
certainty was that the young and
impressionable mary marsmanter fell in
love with a mentor there was never any
hard evidence that he reciprocated her
feelings as far as charlotte shelby was
concerned she had an alibi-ish a man
named carl stockdale claimed he was with
her at the time of the murder and that
the two played cards between 7 30 and 9
30 p.m even so she remains to this day
the favored suspect of many people who
believed that charlotte shelby simply
bought her alibi even her own daughters
accused her of the crime merriminter
made ambiguous illusions but her sister
margaret shelby also an actress doubt
rice said that her mother killed william
taylor however both sisters hated their
mother so despite a grand jury inquiry
into charlotte shelby's guilt a
conclusion was reached that there was
insufficient evidence for an indictment
these are just the major suspects there
were many others a connecticut man
describing himself as an avenging
husband wrote a letter confessing to
killing taylor for having an affair and
later scorning his wife in 1964 an
actress named margaret gibson confessed
on a deathbed to doing the deed as well
some rumors claimed that the killer was
an old rival of tailors from these
klondike gold rush days others said that
it was a canadian soldier who bore a
grudge against the director from world
war one even the ira and the ku klux
klan were suspected by some but alas
many were named many even confessed but
none were ever convicted alongside the
fatty arbuckle trials and a couple of
other scandals the murder of william
desmond taylor became a rallying point
against hollywood for those who decried
its licentiousness and called it
american sodom and gomorrah in a bid to
survive the movie industry decided to
police itself and enacted the haze code
which went on to shape hollywood up
until the late 1960s while skeletons
such as taylor's murder were locked in
the closet and forcefully forgotten
you